should Europe carry on as usual do less  or do much more together commission  president younger stood out five  scenarios ranging the gamut in  Parliament 3.1 million European citizens  live in the UK today EU law makers say  their free movement needs to be  respected at least until the UK leaves  the union MEP is called on Washington to  grab the same visa-free access as other  Europeans to Nationals of five EU  countries bulgaria croatia cyprus poland  and romania after 29 meetings over the  past year the inquiry committee on  emissions has delivered its final report  calling for stricter controls  [Music]  member states spend twenty percent of  their health budget on medication and  the peace call for more affordable  prices especially for new drugs  [Music]